je vous explique je vous le dit tout de
go que c'était mission est mon rêve
voilà non mais attendez ça fait combien
de temps qu'on secoue non non je vous
supplie qu'on parle des intestins des
gaz et du nerf vague c'est vrai moi je
me disais en vous regardant droit dans
les yeux je stimulerait bien
quand j'ai su ce que je peux rêver
je rêve que je suis hantée par
je rêve que je te cette barre à
une déclaration de doha
d'après un sondage très sérieux plus de
76% des femmes britanniques déclarent
avoir honte d'aller à la selle dans des
situations dit donnons l'intimité comme
au boulot contre seulement 26 % des
hommes qui sont beaucoup plus à l'aise
sur le sujet autre exemple est toujours
d'après ce sondage la moitié des
salariés et es préfère un aller retour à
la maison plutôt que de faire la
commission la grosse du moins sur le
lieu de travail pour seulement 16% des
hommes qui ont moins de scrupules en la
matière
c'est
[Musique]
c'est paris
l'odeur et le bruit apparaissent comme
les raisons principales de cette gen
essentiellement féminine est à l'origine
de nombreux troubles gastriques comme
les constipation agathe sans oublier les
risques de tensions et de saignements
que cela peut entraîner pour soulager
les femmes une marque britannique a donc
décidé de commercialiser une poudre
magique une poudre magique à tous les
faits qui permet un la discrétion en
amortissant la chute des selles dans la
cuvette plus de bruit donc vous passez
en mode silencieux voilà
[Rires]
autre avantage la tranquillité
olfactives puisque cette poudre masquer
l'odeur grâce à ses agents actifs fini
donc la honte quand quelqu'un passe aux
toilettes juste après vous vous n'aurez
plus loin d'accuser à tort votre
collègue
[Musique]
gémellité de beauté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas laisser passer images c'est beau
si le bonheur est dure à définir est dur
à atteindre peut-être la joie est
davantage possible au sens où la vraie
joie est une joie lucide sur tout ce qui
va mal une joie contrarier une voix
paradoxal est en fait si on attend que
toutes les conditions du bonheur soir en
soit remplie pour être joyeux heureux on
ne le sera jamais en revanche on peut
apprendre à dire village de cieux je
suis j'ai de la joie de vivre de créer
d'inventer un monde meilleur malgré tout
j'ai la joie bien que il met de plus en
plus difficile de ne pas partager ma
vérité sur les réseaux sociaux à tous
ceux qui luttent parfois entendre que
l'on n'est pas seul et tout ce dont on a
besoin rappelons que bella 25 ans n'a
jamais caché souffrir régulièrement de
dépression une confession qui pourrait
donc contribuer au débat nécessaire sur
la santé mentale et les réseaux sociaux
c'est humain compte instagram tu es un
créateur ou une créatrice est le slogan
de ce salon certains ont carrément fait
leur métier on va aller les rencontrer
et puis je vais en profiter pour aller
leur demander deux trois conseils
c'est dans ce lieu branché de la
capitale que la plateforme a donné
rendez vous aux professionnels comme et
aux débutants comme moi pour quatre
jours des changes sur ce que 55 % des
18-34 ans voit comme un métier d'admis
français d'être
allemange et à liège qu'est ce que la
télé 3d on sait très bien que ma soeur
et moi on est patrick explique qu est ce
qui est vraiment intelligent ou alors si
l'eau qui se trouvait en plus ce que
j'apprends que le mec qui parle cinq
langues
c'est énorme je sais pas pour vous mais
pas les auteurs de langue est vivant moi
j'appelle rappelle qu'une est encore
bien qu'on fera pas forcément puisque le
produit quand j'étais jeune la
surpopulation mondiale c'était vraiment
une préoccupation là il dit vous devriez
lire un livre un peu plus récent est en
fait le risque c'est la dépopulation et
la réalité ce canton passe de 6,2 de 1,2
à 1,5 on est encore très très loin du
taux de renouvellement et le déficit si
je me souviens d'un des chiffres c'est
de 50 millions en 2030 déficit de
population pour l'europe entière
va perdre cette bataille avec très très
compliqué pour moi la moindre petite
bête même une fourmi par le contrôle de
mon corps j'ai trop peur des insectes je
suis à secteur phobie donc c'est pas
qu'ils aient moins de man qui est
embêtant c'est que c'est plus de vieux -
deux jeunes un système de santé de
retraite catastrophique donc il faut
bien remplacer des jeunes par d'autres
jeunes en faisant des enfants soit en
faisant venir montrant les frontières
c'est la réalité dit c'est sous deux ans
terminée le prototype 2 qui a pour elle
et lui allaient dans les villes et à
partir de ce moment-là peut-être dans un
an quand j'ai commencé à parler
d'industrie anisation je m'aperçois que
quand à 14 on a peu goûté un robot comme
moi c'est qu'on a un peu raté sa vie
quand même la scène est inouï
l'homme à la tête coincée à l'intérieur
du volant et ses devoirs du décoincer la
bourse avoir conversé l'armée le
sculpteur là si on arrive à tourner le
volant légèrement est-ce que vous avez
rencontrés à tata
et ça va passer là ça va passer allez
c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour vous
aider
la possible pour les pompiers de le
dégager sans le blesser
si vous trouvez que la chance n'est
jamais de votre côté cette vidéo va vous
prouver que vous êtes au contraire né
sous une bonne étoile
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas du
conducteur de cette dépanneuse qui
cumule un certain nombre de situations
fâcheuses il aurait clairement dû rester
couchés aujourd'hui
[Musique]
essaient de sortir
on vous tient le volant juste à
s'entraîner sortira tranquillement voilà
super très bien dans la sphère de
l'agression des joueuses du psg aminata
diallo elle nie formellement avoir
orchestré l'attaqué contre sa
coéquipière et kheira hamraoui elle a
été placée en garde à vue un temps mais
finalement laissé libre sans aucune
charge contre elle en tout cas c'est de
jouer grâce à elle on a parlé un peu
plus du foot féminin ces dernières 24
heures et elles savent désormais ce
qu'il reste à faire fauqué stapin
escorte qui s'appellerait zaio qu'elle
refuse de descendre du bus la prochaine
coupe du monde et qu'elle envoie des
projectiles sur un public bah oui là le
foot féminin aura enfin rattraper son
retard sur le foot basculant vous dites
un peu n'importe quoi là laurent ans on
voit les souvenirs
c'est ma première fiancée
des valérie ça me fait bizarre dit
bonjour
c'est valérie boyer d'annoncer la fin
cela m'a fait bizarre ben oui ils nous
regardent peut-être valérie dit fait
déjouer embrasse très fort il vous a
dépensé
n'oubliez de vous le dire c'est nul oui
bah je dis n'importe quoi mais en ce
moment on peut dire n'importe quoi à la
télévision ça qui est bien même sur des
sujets sérieux ça devient pas très grave
tout le monde s'en fout